mesdames ravi de vous rencontrer à
l'occasion de la sortie de votre film
birds of prey la fabuleuse histoire
d'harley quinn house avait dans notre
émission en france on adore s'amuser
ouais pourquoi je vous ai préparé une
interview déjanté à l'image de beaux
personnages et de votre film c'est très
simple pour gagner il faut répondre sans
concession à toutes mes questions
d'accord avec toi c'est une blague
j'espère qu'on peut noter la soirée
pyjama cours commente une pin français
des mojitos vous allez choisir parmi
trois fiches qui correspondent à trois
ils voulaient j'ai deux questions
alors vous avez les questions déjanté
vous allez devoir nous révéler à vos
plus grandes folies ya toute la france
il y a les questions sur birds of prey
sur le film évidemment et enfin les
questions h ku sur le personnage
iconique d'harry queen est ce que vous
êtes prêts à y aurait dit oui oui oui
[Rires]
c'est moi qui devrait leur faire faire
la carte déjanté quelle est la chose la
plus déjantée que vous ayez vécu à la
fois par amour ou par amitié à chacune
d'entre vous alors ça va on s'éclate
copistes mesdames
[Musique]
alors vos personnages dans le film sont
mis à rude épreuve avec beaucoup
d'action est ce que vous avez fait un
entraînement particulier pour intégrer
ce long métrage nous à cibler toutes les
on sortira pas dit si vivante à l'égout
très bien alors vous prenez le
personnage iconique d'harley quinn
expliquez-nous qu'est ce qui vous
inspire chez elle qu'est ce que vous
aimez particulièrement dans ce
personnage
[Rires]
mesdames merci pour cette interview
unique et totalement déjanté et
d'ailleurs quand je suis venu ici on m'a
donné une mission celle de vous inviter
en personne sur le plateau de touche pas
à mon poste pour découvrir les missions
les plus déjantées du paf et son
animateur aussi déjanté que ali queen
d'ailleurs je vous adore
il vous en face
bonjour il vous donne l'invitation ici
deux ou trois paris vous m'appelez et au
liban
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]